today we will be looking at the biggest
symbiotes that have been showcased in
movies comics and other media as well
first of all symbiotes are amorphous
living entities that need to bond with a
host in order to become whole and in the
process enhances the merged entities
powers as well as bring forth new ones
so these symbiotes don't have an exact
size since they can shape shift and
adjust their sizes according to
situations but then again it has limits
so we will showcase seven of the biggest
that have been seen so far in ascending
order so let's get to it
number seven carnage first on this list
we have the son of venom which is none
other than carnage and although normally
in the range of eight to ten feet tall
carnage has a great ability of extending
his size and grow exponentially by
spreading his constituent matter like
virtually in all directions
but the biggest form that we have seen
of him so far is in the latest movie
venom let there be carnage and in the
final scenes of his battle with venom he
actually grew to be around 20 meters
tall like around 65 feet and could have
been more if he needed to be
number six the symbiote dragons null the
god of the symbiotes during his initial
war with the celestials and creation
managed to create weapons out of the
abyss and they are called symbiote
dragons like grendel and the world
killer powerful enough to kill most
girls the symbiote dragons were used as
everything from mounds to weapons of
mass destruction capable of annihilating
entire civilizations and their
constituted living abyss could be used
to smother entire planets or infect gods
and mortals alike they are normally in
the hundred feet range
number five gigantic venom well what's a
symbiote lives without venom in it venom
normally is in the range of 79 feet tall
but he became so much more in one of his
recent appearances but before that he
had already became giant venom and
rivaled the size of the frost giants in
issue 14 but in issue 34 of the recent
venom comics venom and eddie came back
from the hive mind of the symbiotes and
chose the size of a gigantic
godzilla-sized symbiote being several
stories tall able to kill the big
symbiote dragons by squishing them with
his hands
number four the celestial symbiotes
null in the recent king and black comics
was revealed to have killed quite a
number of celestials and infected them
with the symbiotes these symbiote
celestials were called down to earth to
fight the avengers and many of the
world's heroes during his invasion
and since we do know that the celestials
tend to normally be in the size range of
2000 feet or 600 meters tall so we can
also come to a conclusion that these
symbiote celestials are in the same size
range they became one of the deadliest
symbiotes ever but they lacked the power
of the celestials
number three iron man celestial extremit
originally one of the army of the
symbiote dragons brought down by the
symbiote god null during his invasion of
earth a symbiote was targeted by iron
man and using a dose of the
techno-organic virus extremists iron man
attempted to rewrite the symbios dna to
sever its connection to the null's hive
in the process of subduing the symbiote
the creature infused itself to iron
man's armor and became the extreme beard
iron man used the extremia to hijack
control of one of the celestials and use
it against null thus becoming a unique
celestial symbiont
number two null yes of course now the
creator of the symbiotes itself is in
this list and he has extreme control of
the symbiote constituted matter and can
transform into and wield it as an
extension of himself in many instances
but while he is a god of the void he is
not the primordial darkness itself if he
was then he would have been infinite in
size but even so during the king and
black issues when he invaded earth his
symbiote constituted matter covered the
entire planet and trapped the world in
darkness so that was his biggest size as
of yet the size of earth
and number one the all black all black
was the first symbiote and was created
from the dark god null's shadow and
tempered with with the divine force of a
killed celestial all black was primarily
a sword composed of living darkness
wheeled by null during the evil god's
demented rampage giving it the nicknames
the neck resort and the god slayer all
black has in the past bonded with
galactus turning him into the butcher of
worlds and with ego the living planet
turning him into the necro world
therefore becoming a symbiote with the
size of a planetary range in the case of
ego and in the cosmic scale in the case
of galactus
so yeah that's all i have about the
biggest symbiotes and if there is
another entry then do share it with us
in the comments section below so anyway
with that we come to the end of the
video do hit that like button for
support
and subscribe to be a part of the
minecube family but most of all smash
that bell icon for regular updates on
new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam